all right
we are live
with natalie cetune
hello
hello
thanks so much for coming on the show
thank you thank you for having me
the founder author creator of insolent
so excited
thank you
we have some epic visuals to share with
the audience as we as we chat
yeah
these are really good visuals
yeah
thank you
super looking forward to sharing these
thank you
wow
nice
[Music]
so
let's start things off by
exploring
how did
your journey lead here
[Music]
a curious girl
a curious girl that uh
every answer she received
was only a partial
perspective about
her true knowing talking about a very
young girl five years old six years old
maybe eight
every answer every perspective every
discipline every encounter
just a partial
answer
and
i said okay well
i i don't know why facebook came but
uh if there is no
platform
that can allow this young gentleman at
the university in the dorms then he
created it
right
to be able to chat and connect with
peers friends colleagues
so something like this happened to me uh
i'm a curious girl
both a girl and an old wise woman
[Music]
and
i'm
i went through many many teachings and
uh
understandings
but each one of the teachings and the
teachers and the disciplines and the
perspectives gave me only
this light disliked yes so think about
an elephant
these these were amazing talking about
the tasks these were amazing talking
about the ears the eyes the
the
social structures of elephants amazing
perspectives but nobody really
can give you a true understanding of
what an elephant is
and this is how insolent journey started
it started from sciences through
psychology through clairvoyance
energy work
communication with extraterrestrial
uh
and then just pure transmission
uh so there are many many stops along
the way
and
basically what i am is just a vessel for
this
for this 360 degree elephant
i'm just in a live tradition
it's not even like the theory or the
mathematics or the physics or the
psychology
of what we will talk about it right now
it's never stable and it's never
this is how it is this is the number one
this is number two this is number three
everything is alive and everything is
becoming all the time
so the way we perceive reality and the
way we
interact with reality and the way we
think about reality impacts reality
informs it and creates with these new
uh
new information
so all this is alive in me and um
from the little girl to the
i would say wise woman have always been
with me and now is it's really being a
channel a channel for this
magnificent absolutely magnificent
becoming
yeah
i feel as though that's what primarily
gravitated
us
is
the
super curiosity about the nature of
reality and also noticing that
answers that we were getting were
partial
and that in order to come to a holistic
answer we would have to take it on
ourselves
um and that even though we are
in process of
creating a map of the territory which is
impossible
um we're getting as close as we can the
territories perpetually becoming
um
and we're getting as close as we can
and taking into account
not only math physics science but also
spirituality mysticism
god infinity emptiness void and so
the
yeah to really
nail that is a lifelong work of
excitement
and uh that definitely feels like why
we're yeah gravitated towards
each other
and and you know not only that
we are trying to
articulate the landscape
the way the landscape arises
the way it arises the mechanism the
process and the structure it arises is
also changing and what we want to
decipher is how is it changing
while we are deciphering it
yeah so there's no
theory of everything out there we're
gonna get
the mass energy
um quantum particles uh
and then that's it we nailed it yeah we
have it we got it this is what it is
this is how the universe works well it
doesn't
do because the universe is alive
it's like you and i it's an alive
excited
wounded
full of potentiality
being
so as we are deciphering the landscape
and as we are deciphering
wow look at this green meadow look at
this mountain look at this beautiful
stream
uh
the canyon as we are deciphering the
landscape it's actually
morphing and changing in front of our
eyes
so what i actually realized and this
really allowed me to become very humble
is that
it does take a village and it takes a
village of reality explorers
like you and i and all the people you
bring on your show
independent out there thinkers not
necessarily the the
kind of mainstream
uh
you know vedic
uh psychologist i mean i actually won
the one that are like what what is he
talking about these are the really
interesting explorers and it takes a
village to bring us together
and say hey hey tell me what you see and
what do you see and what do you feel and
how does it type to this and once we
actually have
a true
collective effort
to decipher to decode reality this way
the same way we're doing let's say with
the human genome the same way we're
doing with quantum physics with
computational science we actually have
hundreds of thousands of researchers
around the world and billions of dollars
really directed toward these fields
nobody is really directing energy or
concerned effort or consciousness or
budgets toward reality exploration what
is reality not necessarily what is
physics physics is only one aspect the
psychology perception the non-dual is
just an aspect there's a whole field
that nobody is really exploring together
as a village and i feel like this is
part of my uh my calling in this
lifetime
yes
exactly
potentially across multiple
lifetimes this this is our oh yeah
our blueprint
our calling yeah
it's perfect yeah and
to allocate civilizational resources to
um understanding um who we are and why
we're here is um one of the best things
that we can do because then as we
realize
um that influences every single one of
our actions into the field so
yeah
yeah
so cool so that's great that's great
context and background now
um
so so natalie um let us know here um i
would love to begin sharing some of the
um visualizations
um and have you begin um ex
explaining to us what they are and how
they tie into this
um
this
uh cosmology of reality and
consciousness
and
um and you but you already did a version
of of insolent um in 2016 is that right
the first version yeah 2018
18 was that was the first version
that was the first version right it was
the beginning it was the beginning yes
okay and then so 2018 was version one
and now this
what we're what we're about to share
with you guys is version two which is
um
it's almost fully complete
um
and to be published likely by the end of
this year by the end of 2021
yes okay
okay great and it'll be published um
it's like an upgrade of version one yes
oh yeah it's it's a much deeper and
broader
and more expanded
so basically version one
it's interesting version one
talks about my life journey
and it
was just the beginning of installment
transmission
uh
since then uh i presented the model in
different consciousness uh
in reality um conferences and
different venues and then i received
many questions that were very potent and
they started this
kind of ignited me to ask
myself this question and start
writing the answers to the questions
so installment 2 which you're about to
see actually will be published later
this year
and most of the images because i i see
things
as images as mental image pictures a lot
of the information comes to me as
pictures i'm actually also a trained
clairvoyant so
um
this channel is very open you know in
this vessel
and this is something i'm sharing with
the viewers and the listeners because
each one of us actually have many
capacities and the more we use
a specific capacity this capacity
becomes
like an open channel
to receive and process information this
way okay so it happens for me so
that the the most of the data most of
the information it comes as
as visuals so um
before we we start with the actual
images i want to share
that
the word installment comes from the word
soul
and it's the ongoing process of being
and becoming
and expressing
potentiality to actuality potentiality
to actuality that's the installment
process now now even the word
installment it's not my word it just
came to me okay there's no such word in
english
um
and it's the ongoing becoming
now there is
because we are thread
we are a thread you are a thread i'm a
thread each one of our listeners
we are threading the soul of the world
so
our own
potentiality to actuality becoming of
our own soul is actually literally
weaving the soul of the world as we
speak
and the soul of the world is infinite
actually a lot of what we're going to be
talking about today is
comes comes
from the realms of infinity though
they're very particular they're very
particular in this in this as they are
expressed in this dimension okay so
i'm saying this because it's a reality
cosmology installment is a reality
cosmology of the becoming of the soul of
the world
now why is it important and who cares
and why is it
uh it's actually critical now i want to
share that i use installment
in my own life in my own
relationship body soul
development and also in my clinic so i
have an installment clinic where i
actually test you know i receive a
transmission i receive
okay do this do that this is how it
looks like this is this is the geometry
then i go and i test it i test it on my
own
life experiences
and then on my on the people who are
actually coming to see me now
this is called an installment clinic
our installment counseling and basically
i'm trying to see
where can i actually apply this model
and how can it actually impact a
person's
experience of its own reality either
sickness
or
mental emotional
imbalance and so forth so actually
installment is not just an idea
it really a very
applicable model
and i actually see it as applicable to
not only individuals but relationships
and nations and continents
imagine america living its soul
imagine israel living its soul imagine
africa living its soul truly living and
embodying the potentiality turning it
into actuality oh my god this whole
world will become
an unbelievable experience
so this is like the context the
background context that this is not just
a theoretical model it's actually a very
very
relevant and potent
uh perspective that can allow us to
install install people in seoul nations
install ourselves
and this installment process is actually
the full expression of who we are right
now
the full expression of who we are right
now
okay
um
so
installment started
with the field of potentialities this is
how the whole
journey started there's a field
let's call it the source
the primordial
it's the field where everything is just
completely realized and in complete
potentiality at the same time it's the
feel of all that is
so that's where the whole
and the field actually still exists
so it's not like it started there and
now we're far away from it
the
primordial field exists
from the primordial field when the first
ripples
starting to differentiate
just a ripple started to differentiate
from that field all of a sudden in
actuality so you have a potentiality
all of a sudden moves into actuality
that actuality started to
turn so-called to the left so called to
the right so-called up and down to
interact
these interactions between the
actualities the first first
tidal waves i would call them they call
them big band i'm not sure if there's a
big bang but there's definitely a first
rippling effect or first movement
in the field of potentiality from that
primordial all of a sudden
essences started to arise
and soon i'm going to show the essences
and everything so it will be easier for
people to make the the connection
um these essences are the kind of great
grandfather of creation
these are the first very very very first
um
let's say element that differentiated
and stabilized so i'm talking about
light and darkness
love and consciousness frequency energy
okay so these are
almost primordial essences that's that's
began
back then but you can treat them as any
other being okay
so you have the primordial layer
so-called layer you have the essential
layer
and then comes the soulful layer
the soul is the unique combination of
essences
so you atlas you're a very unique
combination and you need gra in a unique
gradation of essences
that had a unique journey that's the
thing so you're not only a composition
of essences you also had a very very
unique journey when you turned right
and i turned left our soul
further differentiated from each other
okay so the soul
is the accumulation of all the journeys
that
specifically you have
uh traveled throughout all your journeys
since your inception since your
differentiation so i talked a lot in
installment about differentiation
and about uh
essences and the soul now after the soul
differentiates right now
your soul is expressed as a unique
vessel
so you have your own vessel this
beautiful man that you are
beautiful eye color beautiful lips
beautiful hair
so this unique unique expression of who
atlas is
is your unique vessel in this specific
reality okay so there are multiple
reality that you're currently existing
in
right now you and i are syncing up and
talking in this reality
now your vessel i call it in this is the
vessel realm so we have the primordial
the essential the soul
then we have the vessel a soul in order
to actually express
or be seen or felt she has to enter a
vessel and this is the vessel that
you're entering into
and now how is your vessel and your soul
and everything evolving through
particles of experiences which is the
fundamental
breakthrough in this model that this
whole universe is made of particles of
experiences these are the god particles
they're not the buzon and ozone and all
the other
uh subatomic particles that now we're
building
you know
a huge cern
uh
lab uh these are actually i mean we can
of course find more and more information
about the physical nature of reality the
particular vessel of the physicality of
reality
but actually the world is made of
particles of experience this is very
profound
because once we understand that we're
actually emanating all the time
particles of experiences and actually
interacting our particles of experience
are interacting
then this is how the the whole soul of
the world and the whole
uh process keeps going through having
experiences and the reason realities are
so critical for these experiences is
realities are like little hubs you know
you create your little reality in your
own little room in your own little life
and this is like a little hub of
development and then you grow something
very unique there through this
unique uh containment of your own
reality and while you are having
experiences your vessel is evolving your
soul is evolving the essences are
evolving and the whole primordial is
actually basking in this amazing
pleasure of seeing actuality happening
through you okay so that's that's like
the whole cosmology on one
in kind of a few minutes
whoa
love that yeah that's so good okay so i
love i love how
um
this kind of goes back also
2500 years ago
um one of my favorite learnings from
when i was
studying last year for the for the first
visual book that i made high-level
perception that
it was um heraclitus and parmenidus with
coming and being
and that um
and i love how you merge that with the
potentiality
which which is what many
of the mystics say the true nature of
reality is is just infinite pure
potentiality
um emptiness dancing
as endless taking endless shape name
form
um
and
and then you have then that's the
actualization that's the actuality of
the potentiality
and so i love your um being becoming um
potentiality actuality
that's a really good
foundational
um
way for for our for our audience to be
able to
um formulate a greater metaphysical
understanding
and then because there does seem to be
very clearly um
as you sort of um pierce more and more
into
um
what is uh the infinite absolute reality
that you notice that um there there is
um
you are you are eternity um that is
watching the dances
um you are eternity when participating
in the dance and so there is a
um there's a
there's a there's a comfortability with
the acknowledgement of something that is
um absolutely immovable um that is also
experiencing infinite movement and
infinite dance and play
so
so that was really profound and i loved
also how you began to
break it down on the level of um
just seeing uh
what could it be that is so magical at
the
not only at what we're seeing
as physics describes like a zero point
energy or
or as um
many mystics have called the the most
primordial level of emptiness
um and then all of the crazy um
dance that happens
um that is never
that's always changing like you said
also it's always dynamically changing
which then
which then creates what we see here as
these shapes names forms
and yeah and i love the beginning of
sharing with us those um the essences
like you were like you were saying and i
love how you also called this
this vehicle the vessel that then
is um
what
the particles of experience
uh end up you know you are
that infinite intelligence having the
experience of um your own unique uh you
know take on what it all is and then um
and that's sort of how um as we we've
talked about
before as you migrate between realities
and experiences
that um that we continue
on this
that's why it really feels like a soul
angle if you will where
um it feels like oh well maybe it feels
like maybe i've done this before like
where i i come to realities and i find
some signal and then i distill the
signal and share that with
with civilization
so
so yeah so that's a great is a really
great starting point for us and um
i feel like do you feel like it's
relevant now to share because it's yeah
okay cool so let's let's do that let's
pull that up
um
let's do this motion let's do this yeah
let's do this for now
so i i want to share that this the all
the materials here are eventually going
to be published in the next few months
this year
and they're still draft so there's still
maybe typos here and there and some
you know things that are still
expressing and still be coming
but
in
basically what we're seeing here is a
cosmology a cosmology is a way to view
the cosmos the cosmos
inner and outer cosmos okay now like any
cosmology it has some elements
in in this cosmology so we have here if
i'm going from top left
and i'm going kind of to the right
so
this cosmology basically
let's see
i can see it i can see part of it maybe
you can yes so perfect
so
the vessel which is you and i
are really important elements in this
cosmology so you are considered a vessel
i'm considered a vessel everything that
differentiates that is relatively stable
is a vessel anything a thought a feeling
a memory a movie everything is a vessel
okay and i'm going to talk about vessels
later on so we have vessels
we have sxps sxp is
sole particles of experience
sole particles of experience are these
right now as you and i are speaking even
our listeners our viewers
we are all emanating particles of
experience so your qualia or your
quality of your experience is actually
emanating and radiating
all the time 24 7.
these particles of experiences okay and
you the the content
of your sxp
and the content of my sxp are always
changing based on the quality of your
experience
now because this is such a profound
profound
dynamic and a live model
these sxps are
changing infinitesimally meaning at any
given
all the millimeter okay
because for example when okay so
you have sxps that are that are
emanating from every vessel so even this
cup
it's emanating right now sxp it's
emanating what does it feel like to be a
cop right now in this environment in
this time in this day it's emanating
it's not just like a oh a clay
a bunch of clay from the earth that was
taken and glazed and data it's actually
in a live organism this thing is alive
as well
so everything is emanating as xp's
now we have number three is the soul of
the world
so i see the world the soul of the world
like you said this kind of lila
dancing
being becoming
a fluid
uh
[Music]
magical
uh
organic
organic and unorganic
entity okay which is the soul of the
world
now we have uh
realities let's see i'm trying to see
maybe i can view it
i'm trying to see if i can view it on my
computer then
just a second
okay great i can see it now
so now each one of the vessels create a
reality
so right now you and i
atlas we created a reality together
and the viewers who are with us are
actually inside our reality and we are
inside their reality and we're just
sharing the same auditorium that's what
we're doing so we're creating realities
all the time and realities are actually
the leading edge the cutting edge
technology
of the soul of the world of the becoming
process of the expansion how come
everything is always expanding where is
it going and how is it so different from
each other all the time it's because of
this technology of creating reality so
reality creation and reality
experiencing
is actually a technology that the soul
of the world and the universe
is using in order to evolve
just a second
[Music]
okay
now
uh
we have okay now we have the now all
right
one of the ways to to share that also be
something like
that
this
so the one the one infinite intelligence
uses
souls
to
experience the realities
the one infinite intelligence
the one infinite intelligence is a soul
in it for itself
so
so
when when we talk that we are all one
because we are made of the primordial we
are made of the essential we are made of
souls
we are made of vessels we are made of
particles of experience and this whole
process is emanating almost like a
fountain
it's emanating it's it's it's a rising
it's peaking
and then it dissolves into the
primordial it we actually are
enriching and expanding the primordial
and this this one intelligence is
actually made of the same substances
that we are made of okay we are made
like
like this one intelligence so
soul is just one
aspect of this one becoming intelligence
and and
creating and experiencing realities is a
technology is a way of being and
becoming okay it's it's almost like an
encapsulated field
because see if we i mean i was pondering
about it why do we need realities why do
we need why do we need to encapsulate
realities and our experiences in a
in a
in kind of an enclosed
because if you have an environment
and everything in the environment is
constantly changing there's no
development okay so what we're doing is
we're actually creating an encapsulated
kind of controlled environment so-called
control like right now we have a corona
reality we have an earth reality we have
a country reality okay
so
this this um
reality which is like a space it's like
a space that's allow us to experiment
and to develop a unique
language or unique capacity because see
let's say you want to learn english
but you keep learning all the languages
all the time changing how will you learn
the language you could learn but it will
take you a long time so let's say you
want to learn a language you create a
reality for learning english you learn
you learn the abc
and that's how you actually
um evolve okay so
reality is actually a technology for
this let's call it one intelligence or
one soul of the world
to evolve and to continue expanding okay
yeah so there you go yeah yes perfect
yes
great
now
we have the now on number five now
is this zero point this now right now
you and i and all the listeners
right now
this is the point
that connects us to all the realms
to infinity this now not that right now
this is it
this is it no there's nothing we don't
need to meditate on mountains or or you
know do all these rituals we
we just tune in it's about tuning in
you tune into the now and through the
now
uh it's true we have a coronal illusion
but hey we're all living in this
illusion so somebody wrote here andres
you're absolutely right and there's we
have a corona illusion but guess what
if everybody creates the illusion
everybody enters the illusion
then we're all together in this reality
illusion it's true
it's true
okay so okay but i love it i love i love
these comments i wish i could comment on
them while still talking to you so the
now is this uh
but but guess what that's the thing
illusions become realities the more
they're populated okay
if you have a reality let's say you
created an illusion you created a
completely hallucinatory illusion okay
illusion illusion is like what the hell
it's
there's nothing real about it there's no
monsters there's no
knights there's no white horses what are
you talking about
well if you create an illusion and
enough residents and enough visitors go
inside this illusion it becomes a very
strong stable reality this will happen
with corona apopo okay i'm going to move
it inside so from the now
we're moving to the essences so we have
12 essences these are the 12 essences
that influence our own reality and like
i mentioned earlier there's light and
darkness there's a
the
feminine and the masculine aspect of the
universe there's love and energy
consciousness frequency so all these are
the essences exactly
great
let's go to number seven so i mean i can
go each one of them that's part of my
webinar but but that's okay so anyway
there's a language here so what we're
doing right now we're starting to
establish the cosmology now i'm saying
this because the part of what i teach is
how a person can actually build and
create their own cosmology because what
the world right now needs is people like
you atlas and people like all our
viewers to start articulating their
cosmologies
articulating them
in any way shape or form because when
you articulate a cosmology you can share
it among your peers and when you can
share you create a collective
intelligence that is much stronger
together so what we're doing right now
we're literally introducing
um the elements
that build the insomn cosmology
and
trust me if you sit down and you have
all the knowledge that you got you can
actually put it in your cosmology and
then in this cosmology becomes a living
organism in it for itself and then it it
informs my cosmology it informs our
friends cosmologies and then together
they evolve
now
understanding and evolving cosmologies
will really help us
decipher the code the process and the
structure of reality okay so reality
will not just reveal itself it needs a
language it's need a vessel remember we
started the whole presentation with a
vessel that if something does not have a
vessel
it cannot evolve and if something
doesn't create a reality it does not
evolve
so cosmology is one way
of reality understanding itself
and when many cosmologists imagine
imagine a million cosmologies coming
together talking with each other we'll
have a really better understanding of
the elephant
of this intelligence divine intelligence
we're talking about okay so we have the
the essences that are the 12 essences
that that emanated
after that what do we have here i'm
going to just
glance through them because there's so
much there
uh so these are kind of the fundamental
language it's like the abc of insolvent
cosmology
so we have the uh yes these are the five
rounds we talked about earlier
primordial essential sulfur vessel and
particles of experience and this is how
it's continuously emanating okay so
these particles are continuously
emanating right now this is what you're
doing from your little chair in
amsterdam this is what you're doing
you're emanating particles of
experiences okay and this is how you're
actually expanding the realities around
you
so uh i'm gonna just look here
there's entrainment so the whole fabric
of reality is in trained
this is why it's known local
non-temporal the whole fabric the whole
fabric is emerging
there's a
torus shape to it
there's primary influences there's the
nested structure to reality
so the same way your body
atlas if i'm going too fast too much
tell me i'm going to slow down as you
can see i'm i get excited so if i i need
to slow down just let me know okay
feeling feeling really good about the
pace yeah okay awesome awesome so
so there is there are primary
influencers on our reality the reality
is nested so if you look at your body
for example
you say well i'm i'm kind of a bag of
bones with muscles with heart with
organs but then the more you go down
down down it's all nested
so basically
there's the macro then there's the the
tissues
then there are the organs the cells the
cells has a micro so basically all of
reality is is nested
and this happens
at all levels which is fascinating
because what happens with nested reality
they also apparently are supporting
evolution of reality technology because
when things are nested it's almost like
included transcend so you are able to
actually include and transcend
everything you have in your body and
become more so this is kind of that
nature
and when realities develop this way
versus develop in a different
configuration
this is a much
more efficient way to develop realities
when they're nested okay
so realities are nested everything has a
perspective i'm going to 13. everything
has a perspective so
everything we're talking about there's
somebody who is saying
okay let me look what's going on here
there's a perspective perspective not
only seeing
but truly having a lens on something
okay
um when your sxps are rippling they
leave trails behind
almost like effervescence like think
about it a lady comes in or a gentleman
comes in with a beautiful colon
natural organic colon with like a
beautiful lemon and when he leaves the
room when he leaves the room there's
like ripples that he leaves behind
ripples of his of his essence of his
sxp's okay a person who's sensitive
enough and i i talk about the the
futuristic technologies that will be
able to detect sxps we're very far from
there but it's possible you actually are
able to detect the ripples that every
person that everything leaves behind and
this is actually how clairvoyant
clairsentient sears that's what they see
they see all the ripples and the trails
that
vessels leave behind okay so you have
ripples then you have sxp cosmic dust
that's flowing through us
you have a reality landscape this is we
were talking earlier about the landscape
every reality leaves a landscape that's
amazing because see
let's say we had a corona reality right
now a corona illusion okay
and um
20 years from now in 2040
the corona
would have left a reality landscape
imprinting on our collective psyche on
our physicality on our experiences
so there's always a landscape that's
left because we are in dimension of time
and space that's part of the essences
because time and space are are elemental
here
there's always a landscape
and the landscape can be revisited and
this is how you can go far
back and far forward because you can
actually visit landscapes because things
live landscapes realities leave
landscapes behind okay so the coronal
reality even though it will be like oh
far gone we're not thinking about it
actually there's a landscape that's
already imprinted in the collective
field both the physical emotional trauma
field all the all the fields that we are
we are alive in okay so this is the uh
the landscape
uh we talked about cosmic dust there's
also a cosmic wave
there's a reality landscape fabric so
not only that there's a there's a
landscape there's also a fabric
the every landscape has a fabric and
guess what the fabric is changing
so corona for example in 2040 when we go
and revisit let's say we have
a unique eyes that can see the corona
reality
we i can actually see the fabric and how
it changes now the fabric itself will
change based on our 20 years
experiences that we're going gonna have
okay
so every reality has a landscape it has
a fabric
uh every reality now i'm going to the
next uh aspect of the the installment
which is the sensorio
so what is so unique about a vessel
is that every vessel
is a unique development of sensorium
unique
set of sensorium now
for example
when we develop an eye let's say like in
this sensory main eye or in here
our eyes
enter
a dimension of all eyes in all
dimensions everywhere
so a frog eyes with your eyes
with uh an ant eye
all this is the sensorium level
that that is created
yeah
common serum laughing so no it's okay
it's so good yeah i love it it's still
here
so
so um
atlas
what happened your ability to see
the minute you develop a vessel because
see you are a vessel but you also are
made of of uh nested vessels okay so
your ability to see
is actually a unique vessel that your
both your personal and our collective
humanity developed
but also all the other species have
developed ways of seeing also deep sea
creatures they have developed developed
way of seeing
this ability to see
and to receive impulses
is a realm it's a whole is a whole round
that i call in sensorium sensor is
really critical because through
sensorium we understand our perspective
and our perception
okay but this is why biomimicry works so
well okay because they're looking at a
lizard and they're like how come she's
upside down and she's still stuck to the
to the ceiling how can she do that how
what what suck sucking um
you know mechanism that she has on on on
her legs and feet on her that allows her
so she develops she developed a
mechanism so now we can take that
capacity which we don't have as humans
and we can develop a technology now i
have a big deal a big conversation about
technology here because i feel what's
happening
if we're talking about technology
which we haven't really touched this
topic at all there's a huge issue that
we are dumbing ourselves down we are
dumbing ourselves down
by developing and
exporting
all of our capacities to machines
okay
now i'm not saying we we cannot go back
because there is a an exponential
development of technology but there's a
way in which technology and humanity can
actually have
a
a supportive evolutionary trajectory
versus
technology is going to consume
humanity and we're actually going to
become dumber and dumber and dumber
unfortunately
we don't use our navigation system
anymore we use
waze and gps
because we're dumbing ourselves down we
don't know the connection between the
sun in the direction anymore we're just
using the technology
and that's that's a whole other
conversation that i talk about at the
end of the book
okay so um
so network everything is networked
everything goes through a life cycle
everything goes through a life cycle
nothing stays the same all the time
because this is a part of the
evolutionary trajectory so everything
goes through a life cycle arising
peaking
blossoming and then going to
non-existent and comes again
everything is communicating
so like i mentioned even the cup
right now you and i are communicating
with each other
now what's interesting is realities also
have a behavior realities are also being
and organisms and they tend to aggregate
into realms and dimensions okay
so what's happening is actually
reality
let's say the corona reality for example
aggregate with the healthcare reality
with science and research so realities
tend to aggregate with each other and
tend to speak with each other
realities are in train they harmonize
and they synchronize
because this is this is a high return on
investment in terms of uh
compared to chaotic
unrelated unentrained unharmonized
unsynchronized uh behavior
and then realities have a gravitational
pull so guess what and this is i'm going
back to the corona the reason the corona
was such
a big deal
is because in 2020 compared to let's say
2000 or 1950s
we had a whole dimension which is called
social media and media in general
and what happened with media
it's it's
exacerbated this whole
phenomena
and it created a whole field
that's called the corona field and it
started pulling people in
so realities have gravitational pull
technology has gravitational pull
science and technology so basically all
realities that you create have a
gravitational pull
the way you could view it if you look
let's say i don't know what's what's
who's your favorite football or i don't
know i'm not i'm not a sports fan but
if you go to a stadium and there's like
let's say 10 000
nfl i don't know
think about the energy in that stadium
right and how much gravitational pull it
has the more a reality has subscribers
the more that reality pulls
energies and pull participants in and
this is what happened with the corona it
would not have happened if we would not
have developed our social media to this
extent
i think it would have been much much a
different experience
okay so i'm going to pause here
uh
there's so much to tell you i mean i
mean i mean if you want to go but
there's so much i'm going to pause and
i'm going to maybe let you or people ask
questions however you want to go with it
wow
yeah
damn
that's so rich
wow
yeah because um
i've noticed this about myself as well
is that
finding these patterns and then aiming
to communicate them through
visualizations seems to be one of the
best ways to do it and so while i'm
looking at all these different patterns
that you've um uncovered and are sharing
that i feel so much
full
resonance
with them
and so
yeah specifically um
[Music]
so let's
see here
um
this
so first of all i mean first of all by
far
i think the one that we most overlook
um is this
um what you talked about
we're making um the fact that we have
the power to know
um
so you're you know you're not as you're
not so much a person with the power to
know as you are god or affinity or
eternity or the mystery that has the
power to know and that's what share like
we share the fact that we are that we
are the ultimate we are the absolute
with the power to know at
in this endless infant creation
exploration
and so and then the way that that um
expresses itself is very um it's very
fractally and very emergent
so this is uh probably like the the
second yeah profound one so it's very
fractally it's very emergent
um so emergent emergent sensorium um
i love it
yes it is
i love it i love it you see now look
look what's happening right now we're
just playing chatting
and you're
you're
connection emergent sensorium is very
powerful this can be a whole week of
discussion
and developing
and this is how cosmology is developed
and this is how their self-knowing
intelligent
keep expanding
and we need to find ways we need to find
ways for reality
explorers to share this is this is part
of why i'm gravitating to you atlas
because
me too your perspective this perspective
imagine us
creating something with all this wisdom
oh my god it's so powerful i know yeah
yeah we keep we keep being um
i keep getting these notifications from
my other like really high level um
awakened
um
natalie your uh by the way this video
went off just for a second hold on hold
on i'm going to put it back here we go
yes yes yes
sorry atlas what did you say
no it's just i'm getting so many of
these uh
messages from my other high level
awakened friends from all these
different angles that are saying things
like
um
oh you and your powerful networks um
well you guys are for sure going to
start like mystery school or non-dual
school or
synthesizing science and spirituality
school
synthesizing mysticism and quantum
physics you know and
and so it's it's really exciting that um
like what you just described because
it's totally feeling like it like this
the insolent symbols legend um the
um
the
like the further um distillation of this
into
like virtual reality pedagogy for
five-year-olds um
and
yeah yeah
yeah we have
a lot of beautiful things like this
cooking and it's just it's feeling
really good and we have you know very i
agree like our gravitational pull
together is totally for for this and
um yeah this is so cool this is really
well done i have a feeling like we
should probably continue so that we can
actually uh get through
a lot of uh
the the core should we should keep going
probably right yeah let's keep going
let's keep going to why don't you put it
on the whole screen i i don't know why i
cannot see it can you see it on the
whole
i see it oh oh yeah i'm i'm only seeing
exactly yeah because i have to do this
picture in picture for it uh
yeah
for it to show up bigger okay which i
can if you want to do you want me to
keep it like uh
do you want me to keep it yeah that's
fine
that's fine
it's just a little harder for us to for
the audience to see our faces while we
talk i see
okay why don't you go to slide number
five
oh you want me to go to five okay yes
all right i mean there's so much to
cover here it can take us a long time
yes we could but
cosmetic archetypal influencers
yup cool
cool
all right
so now five
okay here we go cosmology overview yes
this is the overview
so look
remember we talked about
um
so the way the way it is encoded in our
dna of time and space
there's a now in the center there's a
now
then anything underneath it
is almost like
primordial potentiality before becoming
it's a background
i mean if if you want to
you can
you can place the image as you wish
so the whole cosmology is actually
talking
about
in this moment
you have a forefront conscious
and you have a forefront unconscious
you have a background unconscious and a
background conscious
and all this is keep flowing through now
this big wave is the soul of the world
and it's flowing through us
now every vessel creates a reality
and every vessel has a perspective
okay so
this is basically what's happening right
now
as we speak
now if
the the soul of the world is the
totality of all vessels in all times and
all spaces and dimensions that have ever
differentiated
that's the soul of the world that's this
intelligent
being that you were you were referring
to
okay
oh interesting so
so
it
i was feeling like i was about to sneeze
um so
um on the left side um
here so this like soul of the world is
this sort of um one infinite
intelligence one infinite creator
and that
um
and then out of this
total primordial potentiality
nothingness
we have a um
we have an an actualization of of
perspective a vessel perspective for
reality like vessel perspective reality
and um
and then that um
is it's in a constant dynamic dance
um with itself with the other um
uh vessel perspective reality
yes
yeah okay and then that's this one
infinite intelligence
swimming dancing
waving with itself
interpenetrating itself
exactly
cool
i love that
that's great
this is a cool way to visualize it
yes
now now not only that every vessel
creates a reality
every vessel has a perspective and every
vessel is emanating
particles of experience ongoing yeah
okay so then that was interesting so
then
um the vessel
has perspective reality and particles of
experience so not only is
onto this um onto this emptiness this
like empty cognizance of mind nature um
is particles of experience dancing
there but also than how my like vessel
perspective reality interacts with other
vessel perspective reality then that
creates particle of experience for their
in their empty cognizance yeah yes
exactly it's the reason you're always
emanating particles of experience is
because this whole thing is always in
movement and it's the whole thing is
always in relationship
all the time it's it's having
experiences if everything would have
been still
and everything would have been
completely silent and still
and no movement
there's no there's no differentiated
experience there's no interaction
there's no relational everything is just
is okay but the moment now this whole
soul of the world and all the vessels
are are
always evolving and changing and
relating to other vessels
and the relationship
is is
is creating an experience inside you
like your ex our experience of this this
conversation is different than another
person you talked with yesterday because
you have different vessel with a
different perspective with a different
reality
okay yeah so that's what creates the the
variety and this is actually how the
universe expands
through particles of experiences
these are the real god particles
i want to get some more water and then
you can move on or you can ask me
questions
yes please
wanna
want to shout out our
lovely
andy bittner
thank you brother
haha we love you brother
nice
we just got our
book
what is
and um
yeah
um
check out the
win win win
dot earth also for supporting um
the decentralization and
universalization and fractional
ownership of regenerative technologies
we just had a great episode with him
um
yeah yeah people are loving the episode
um
is awesome that's awesome okay so
all right let's continue um
all right so here
um i you know one of the ways that i was
feeling into this that i thought would
be really real share would be you know
how you had as one of your um symbols
you had a communication you had a like
neural communication being shown
um
so basically particles of experience is
kind of like the um the pollination of
like cross-pollination
of of all um with itself
um
yeah great that's great
yeah so yeah that's great so there's
there's little like um
there's these like little air bubbles
that are constantly kind of like moving
um
and interpenetrating into our like
psyches and all that stuff yeah it's
cool
i love that looks really good
awesome so
um
so you so you say that soul of the world
is analogous to
one infinite creator
the one infinite creator
includes all the five realms
includes the field of potentiality
includes the essences the souls the
vessels
their experiences
and think about it on an accumulated
level on an accumulated level which
means since the beginning of time
all the differentiated vessels all the
differentiated waves
all the differentiated experiences and
interactions and realities
all of these
are the soul of the world
so whatever moved from potentiality to
actuality
since the inception
is this soul of the world is this
now
the intelligent creator i see it as the
whole
the
the the whole
uh
set of processes and
emergent phenomena not only
the the one that are actualized but
like i said the potentiality as well
so
yeah yeah
so so the soul of the world is kind of
like the river as it's flowing
the soul of the world is all the
manifest manifested vessels ever
since the inception of
this
this journey
so there is an inception point
and since that beginning
all the vessels that arose
and had experiences
the accumulated
vessels
this is the soul of the world
so of course it's an intelligent creator
now you could you could if if you would
goes particularly we could do an analogy
between
this cosmology and let's say vedanta or
let's say other
other uh perspective and see what is
supreme being what is this so and then
we can actually map them to to to this
but from my perspective from installment
this all over the world is all the ever
differentiated vessels all the
actualized vessels even when they're
long gone
okay cool cool they're still a part of
the soul of the world this is this is
why i talk about a forefront and a
background a conscious and an
unconscious
because let's say what happened 20
million years ago
is still reverberating in our reality
landscape
even though it's in the background of
our unconscious
but it's still here
for example pandemics the reason they're
so scary is because there's in in the
fabric of humanity
there's echoing echoing landscape of
past
uh pandemics
and how they wiped out half of the
population
and this
created a huge trauma activation for the
collective
that brought that experience over there
to here even though it's really nothing
like what it was
okay so i'm saying this because the soul
of the world
is not only what is arising right now
and that's what's the cosmic dust that's
flowing through us right now it's all
that
all the ever differentiated experiences
landscapes realities and vessels
awesome awesome yeah so
there's a
there's a little bit of
um
there's some simultaneity with there
being like absolute tracelessness like
you were indicating earlier um but also
with what has been called like the
akashic records before um where there is
appearance of there also being like this
vehicle this vessel itself is uh over a
period of not only just billions of
years of
of this creation design but also as we
hypothesize previous reality and
creation designs have been using similar
recursive mechanisms like the cell
so
yeah yeah
cool
now
now natalie where do we feel like going
x so this is sick
also i can change it to this what do you
think is best next out of the
let me let me see let me take a look for
a moment
take a look here
and then i'll see what uh significant
information okay
uh well there's so much to say if you go
to number seven
you know what let's go i'll guide you
maybe kind of i i will do some
highlights
and then you know we can always get back
to it so go to number seven
you also have a
you also have like a
like a lineage here where you show
it's a primordial potentiality
to an essential differentiation
soulful
vessel
the soul experience
reality
realms and dimension and then the soul
of world actuality wave
yes
right
cool
cool cool
yeah i like this uh emanating soul um
experiences tori italy
yeah
um that's cool
it's really cool it's really well done
thank you
um
all right so seven yeah okay so if we go
to number seven
um
what happened with perspective
perspective has to do
with some somebody observing something
observing or experiencing something else
and it has to do with the boundary
of your sensorium okay
so a perspective basically has to do
with the boundary of your of your
sensorium if you had really good
night sight
then you can actually see things in the
dark that most people cannot see
and you can actually see all the sxps
that are emanating from what you're
observing
okay so
this has to do with
so perspective is linked to
your sensorium
and the sxps that are
that are
arising and dissolving every moment
that's a perspective
now i'm trying to see
if i want to focus okay let's let's go
to number nine
unless you have questions
okay let's see
you know this is quite well yeah quite
soon i really love the questions i hope
we can go back to the questions later
yeah yeah they're so good i love it yeah
the best
it's a really good tennis it's really
good tennis between us yeah i love it
too it's so nice
um
yeah i love the i love over here it's
just it's quite um some like it's as uh
people have studied metaphysics this
stuff starts making sense like
that your vet vessel creates the
perspective based on its sensorium
and so it's pretty uh it's pretty cool
um from you know can access all scales
from nand cosmic like if you really if
you really tune into it you can begin um
seeing what's happening on the very
like on the nano level with the
sensation that's sort of dancing um in
that empty sense but then you can also
feel the entire sensation that is the
universe itself um right so yeah so this
is great um and yeah we'll we'll also be
able to unpack this more um over more
shows um as well so this is slightly i
think i i don't want to overload but if
me
i mean
you're doing it you're doing so well
you're doing so well i don't want to i
mean listen that that's a lot of
information and uh maybe we can we can
lighten it up maybe we can look at uh
application maybe we can answer
questions i mean we could continue i
mean if you go to number to number nine
yes yes let's let me just take a brief
because i'm trying to at least scan as
we go through
okay do you do what feels right for you
qualities and processes
yep and then this also relates to those
um beautiful symbols that you were
sharing earlier yes oh yeah okay very
cool very cool
all right so there's
uh nesting
um
forefront background
present past future potentialities
entrainment
aggregation to realms dimensions
gravitational pull
communication mirrors
cycles arises peaks dissolves
observation
yeah this is this is really good um we
didn't get to play on on this uh too
much yet but uh we will um likely soon
but um okay
so this is uh
because i i have a feeling that yeah
metamorphosis um
in that uh arising peaking and
dissolving is uh
is one of the core
symbols of the nature of reality for
sure
right sure
cool so
reality
is the vessel's total lived experience
field
nice
nice recorded through its soul
experience trails in all scales
observed by a particular vessel's
perspective
nice
so this this uh
this seems to be in a sense where the
empty dancing
yeah
where the little
um the little sensation is uh
sensations right arising and passing
um
but are they one of the one of the best
questions is are they happening um
to
uh
a
um
a doer are they happening to an
experiencer are they happening you know
or is it just experience is it just
manifestation is it just
um interpenetration of all
um
playing with itself and so i i really
enjoy that question because it shifts us
from
um it just shifts us from having a
locked in subject
um and like being the subject the
individuated subject it shifts us from
that to being nowhere and everywhere
simultaneously
and um that i i have a feeling is a is a
core key is that shift
um from being sort of locked in
awareness on this personal subjective um
to being nowhere and everywhere the
field itself and interpenetrating but
why did you want to pull up uh why'd you
want to pull up nine
because we're talking here about
reality
how we create reality and how we
experience reality
and
when we understand that the reality is
actually all the experiences we're
having
at all scales
then we can
we can navigate and play with it and
modulate it
because see this is not like i mentioned
earlier a theoretical model alone
this can be actually used
and
when you
can modulate your reality and you can
shift
the content of your reality
you can actually start to shift the
personal and the relational and the
collective reality
which i feel is part of the evolutionary
impulse right now we're just going on a
ride
and our participation in reality
is uh
[Music]
is
is very basic our participation and our
steering of or the unfolding of
and there's a way that we can really
become co-creator with the infinite
intelligence that you're describing and
in order to do that we really have to
understand the code and the language and
the mechanism and the process for
reality
because if we don't do that it's almost
like we can drive a car
but we cannot actually build a car
or create a better car
okay
um somebody else created our our cars
somebody else created our cars
or
and they giving it to us and we know
where to get it from
but the i believe the
the next evolutionary impulse collective
evolutionary impulse is for us to truly
understand the fundamental
not only of the nature of reality and of
a theory of everything
but how our experience and our reality
comes into being and then start
influencing it
because otherwise we're just um
going on a ride
and
most of the time there are cosmic
adjustments
to this human experiment on the on this
planet so there's a lot of cosmic
intervention from many many levels and
realms
but uh there's a call here to mature to
wake up to truly wake up
and truly understand the
fundamental principles the fundamental
processes the fundamental
structure
and through this
to inform our next evolutionary
unfolding
which right now we're just going on a
ride and hoping it's going to be fine
so part of this seems like
part of this really seems like the shift
from the victim to the creator
it seems like the shift from just being
or just being the in in the vessel just
i'm in the vessel
to
i'm literally the vibratory infiniti
that is creative like with a stylus with
my will with my awareness with my choice
and so
um so that's that's really beautiful all
right cool
cool
so that's
nine um how realities interact is ten
um yeah do you wanna oh do you wanna
look at where to go next
yes let me take a look okay
okay
and i'll make this picture in picture
for people to see
again
influence i love the graphic for
influence it's so good
nesting
aggregation
weaving
this one's so good it's all about that
inner penetration and influence and
god this one's so good
okay
the actualization of primordial
potential
super positioning
i'm going to let you choose
just just scroll down and just feel
i will
also if you're curious about anything
if you're curious about
um
because i look we've been we've been
sharing this for about an hour and a
half
it's it's a lot i i i feel like
i love you so much i love you so much
you're such a sweetheart i love you
i love you
i can't
i can't uh
you can't express
enough
just
love for you you're you're so on point
yeah you're so on point
thank you
nice you're really i and i love how you
felt into the field a second ago and you
were just like well why don't you keep
looking and then you feel slowly and
then share with me where you want to go
next it's such a perfect way to to take
us into the next step i feel
all right
so let's see what comes up here
and we'll probably go for about 30 more
minutes or so
exploring
interesting a sentient organism field
oh
gosh i love that right there guys
sentient organism field
you know one of the ways that i've been
sharing this
and we'll see
how this plays with you one of the ways
that i've been sharing this with our
audience
also has been
just a shift in the perspective
this will play really well with the
sentient organism field just shifting
the perspective more to
like abiogenesis or cosmogenesis itself
so being
that sentient organism field itself the
whole thing itself dancing playing
interpreting trading
yeah
cool
how to please just like
yes i'm just like feeling into it
because see it's it's all about the
perspective
so when you zoom out you become this
whole organism you zoom in you become
the little ant the little beetle the
little sand grain of sand so you can
play
this is how powerful we are we can play
with all of that now it's nice to go on
a ride
but what i'm saying is
i believe humanity is is
the the the future
i don't know i'm i'm i'm optimistic at
heart but i'm a little bit concerned
with where humanity is going okay
with the transhuman movement and all
this stuff
that we're exporting all these
magnificent
magnificent capacities we're exporting
all of it to machines
and then expecting them to tell us turn
left and right do this
so my concern is that this ability to
zoom in to zoom out to become the soul
of the world to become the the little
grain of sand
to observe to go all the way to the
primordial go all the way to the future
you can actually go 200 years into the
future right now
and you can observe all the
possibilities that are possible for
humanity in 2020
okay we can do that
but because not enough people are
playing with these capacities
it's like not enough people are refining
their psychic capacities
then we're just dumbing and numbing
we're dumbing and numbing this
unbelievable vessel that we are
and now we are at a point in our
evolution that we are self-aware
and we have created a technology that
externalized
all of the data and the information that
humanity collectively is is is
gathering
okay we have the internet and we have
the social media and we have so we have
this kind of mirror that's telling us
look at all this knowledge
okay
and the question is
how do we take it back and how do we
it's not really taking the rain back
like the the rain of the horse because
there's a huge cosmic flow that we're
only a a a a part of it
but we're also because we are also the
soul of the world
we have a huge power
and a huge huge potentiality
okay so my inquiry here
is where is humanity going where are we
evolving into who are we becoming truly
as a species
and this this atlas is not only a
theoretical model
it's a psychological model it's a
relational model
it's an intimate model
it it has to include all these
relational aspects between us
in order to create something that's
greater for humanity
yeah and everything that you're talking
about is also really important because
what what we're currently architecting
with artificial intelligence and
robotics and biotech and neurotech and
all of that is a direct mirror of our
consciousness
so if you feel separation if you feel
ego if you feel lack if you feel un
unworthiness or unwholeness or seeking
validation externally and all these
types of things you're going to build
robots and ais that mimic your level of
consciousness
so
um so the whole the whole game is
to
um up level the density of awareness
love light
so that you're more more saturated with
spiritual nose knowledge or mass
and then as you kill more of the one
infinite creator then everything you do
into the field is automatically going to
be
of the highest caliber expression and
then the field itself all those
architectures will then help serve the
rest of society having increases so the
arc architectures and awakenings
cyclically feed back into each other
so
so if if even before
potentially ai and robots and bio
neurotech etc
would be
fulfilling meeting the basic needs of
people worldwide um they can happen
simultaneously it doesn't have to be one
following the other but that you could
you can guarantee
that
by filling the basic needs of people
worldwide that then they'll be able to
pass more of their time kind of
increasing their metacognition becoming
aware of awareness aware of their
thinking processes
versus being primal and limbic and all
that kind of stuff
and then
um and then
uh with the and that'll naturally unfold
a more harmonious ai robotics next 10 20
20 years but i'm glad that you said that
you also wrote that into the
into the end of the
book as well
because i am concerned i am concerned
like i mentioned i feel
there has to be a very thought through
relationship with technology
because with the level of intervention
that we're uh we're inserting patches of
updating our you know em
you know all the these vaccines and all
this i mean we're entering into
very very highly sophisticated
organisms
and we're inserting
updates we're thinking we're like a
software and hardware
and entering
and injecting humanity with
nanoparticles with
devices
i see this as a great risk great risk
for
[Music]
this human experiment
and i'm concerned about it
look we cannot stop technology
technology is not going to stop it's
already have
it's unleashed itself
the question is what is the right
relationship with humanity
exactly
perfect
perfect
okay so
great
soul includes the totality of all
actualized essences souls vessels soul
experiences and realities
okay cool
gosh this reminds me so much
of
high level perception it's awesome
so so foreign
realities realm
nice okay cool so so is there almost a
um
a primordial potentiality level here um
the 12 essences sort of you know do the
12 essences sort of give rise to
the the kind of the
the soul's experience and the reality
we are made of these essences the
essences are the
first archetypal
initial waves that differentiated from
the primordial they are the first first
great great great grandparents of
everything that arose so we are made of
the essences
so to answer your question yes
because we are made of this yes yeah
very cool very cool so so the the 12
um primordial essences um that that the
the mixture
the mixture of them is what sort of goes
from potentiality to actuality in the
reality
in the soul experience
okay so look the moment something
started to move from the primordial the
primordial is a field of potentiality
with no actuality whatsoever there's no
actuality there's no movement there's
nothing there it's all potentiality it's
the infinite source infinite field
the minute there was a movement any kind
of movement
boom
actuality any movement in any direction
its actuality
it happens so the 12 essences were the
first ones to move
okay
move differentiate and exploring and
interact
so
that movement
birthed
the souls
the soul know how to create their
vessels
and the vessels know
how to have experiences and how to have
realities
this knowing of course is is an
evolutionary knowing it's not just
your
it's
it happened and evolved throughout time
and throughout
the unfoldment of the cosmos
but the ability to create realities and
the abilities to have experiences
like i mentioned this is the most
advanced technology
that we have right now
of course it is listen
of course it what happened yes yeah can
you hear me
now i can hear you okay
okay oh my
gosh of course it is um
of course it is like
you see this is the thing is that we're
not thinking big enough we're not we're
not imagining big enough because if we
did we would recognize that the coolest
technology by far that exists
is universe design is to design
universes and then to have in the
designing vessels
soul vehicles
for experience yes it's so good
it's unbelievable that's unbelievable
it's unbelievable it's so mind-blowing
it's it is it is like it it it makes you
feel like a child
with your innocence and play but then it
also makes you feel like a grandmother
or grandfather like a
stage with wisdom
yes at the same time yeah that's right
this is how we started remember i told
you about
the little girl
the old
okay cool let's let's keep a little of
you let's keep going let's see what else
comes up in the next like 20 minutes or
so let's see
all right cool
okay so these are the qualities and
processes of soul experience who
flickers
each particle each sxp are the particles
okay yes so
so sxp is the soul experience particle
yes it's sold particles of experience
exactly
cool cool
oh this is awesome
yeah this is so good
and especially it's so fascinating
because
the more that we
surround ourselves with like more awake
or more enlightened
beings that we
recognize that they have these qualities
that they they not only have these
qualities they emanate these qualities
or like you say
they ripple these qualities where you
can really feel um you can feel the
field around them being more
peace
love
potentiality you can feel their
sensitivity to the flickering in and out
is the highest yeah
yeah
it's great
it's so good okay i love that
whoa
okay
interesting so then the zero point
center would be sort of this empty
cognizance
yeah okay cool
exactly
cool and then the qualia is what appears
and disappears in the empty cognizant
can you repeat that last sentence the
quality
sorry the quality
yes the qualia would be what appears and
disappears in this empty cognizance
the qualia is the transient content of
your experience in this moment
and it appears and disappears it
flickers in and out exactly
perfect perfect
whoa
interesting so the
so the soul particles of experience
carry information about what it's like
for its vessel
to
be here now to exist to experience its i
am-ness
such a good way to put it
wow
so
your
your unique
um
individuated
um
what it's like to be you now
um
your i am-ness
at the individuated level because it's
all nested so that you can then also
explode that out to this universal great
i am-ness or at the very
tiniest little part particle of
experience level as well but your
general individuated i am-ness is
um moment-to-moment being informed by
the particles of experience soul
particle experience
yes exactly
cool
that's great
that's great so so there's this like
empty cognizant i am-ness
that then is what
has the
the soul particle of experience of
drinking water
yes
yes
that's water
yep
that's great
so
so
so what we share is the empty cognizant
individuated i am-ness
and then it gets a unique particle soul
particle of experience of
your
you know your unique
your phone when it gets its little
modulation of you know natalie's gonna
get a different um message
then atlas will
from a different friend and so that's
your unique little
um
and that's why natalie's costume
character looks a different way than
atlas than yours does
yes this is a great point you're making
oh my god this is really important what
you just said
good good
because wow this is big
this is so important what you just said
so
a set of experiences you will have
repeated experiences or variants over
period experiences you will have
eventually
will
will shape the becoming of the vessel
so let's say right now you're emanating
emanating emanating atlas is emanating
natalie is emanating
repeated experiences emanating let's say
you're just really really happy
that repeated happiness experience or
contentment or peace or joy
well actually
stabilizes and reform your vessel
this is why when you see a person that
had a really hard year or hard time and
you look at them like wow they lost so
much weight the weight they lost their
hair they look so their face is fallen
because all the experiences they've had
and all the sxps they radiated have
impacted their vessel their overall
vessel
so this is really critical information
that particles of experiences that
they're not just momentary arising
because a repeated stream of continuous
uh flow of experiences will actually
shape the vessel will literally shape
the vessel will literally shape the
lines on your face if they're going to
be lifted or fallen or
so this is how critical experiences are
now
your experiences are so important that
they're really shaping your vessel your
physical emotional psychological
relational
uh collective vessel okay for example
the corona
we're talking about it because it's it's
a illusionary phenomenon that happened
in on this in this reality
the the corona has impacted our
collective significantly
look how much impact it had and we can
list all the the impact okay now so what
the corona experience because guess what
there's not only a personal experience
there's a collective experience
so the collective experience of the
corona
has shaped and created dents and created
shapes and movement
and landscape
in the in humanity's collective field
so you don't have only a personal
experience
you have a relational experience you
have a collective experience then you
have humanity humanity as an organism
has been shaped by the experiences of
this last year
okay so
experience is critical
to everything we see around us
so if we know that experience is so
fundamental to reality
then how do we
design
influence
experiences
in a way
that is
pro-humanity pro-earth
pro-evolution that's the question
and people like you and i and people
like our audience
and all the cosmologists the reality
explorers unite
unite to say hey what are we going to do
with all this knowledge i mean knowledge
in it for itself is really nice
what interests me is how it can be used
this is why i started the conversation
with saying if i'm not going to test all
these diagrams
with real cases and see the real
difference where it's actually happening
then it's it's it's a nice theoretical
physics theoretical philosophy but for
me what's what's interesting is the
evolutionary
trajectory of humanity and the earth
that's why we care very much
the clinic and the applicability
and
the immediacy of these practical tools
to support evolution and awakening yeah
totally yes yes
evolution and awakening now
not in 20 years now
now
today
yeah
it's time so it's time
yeah no i know
i know
um
this great that's great so in a sense
it's like a
um
it it's almost like a coloring if you
would it's like a coloring the the soul
particle of experience it kind of colors
shapes
um the soul itself as well um in its
process
so the
the empty cognizance or the boundless
space or the
um
itself the actual um
the actual emptiness itself it's not
like that gets um colored but the
emanation of that which is the soul the
fractal individuation across its
lifetimes of exploration over time
that's why i can't do anything else but
this and likely neither can natalie
anymore we can't do anything else we've
we found exactly what is our unique
blueprint calling and we remembered it
and now there's nothing to do but this
and so that's right
yeah so that's why
um now whatever our soul is getting
colored or picking up with energetically
in this all of the sxps in this
creation in this reality now we then go
on we go onward into the next you know
when you look at the collective that
you're going to incarnate onto next um
you're going to carry with you all of
this to
the essence of this for you to then
bring forth into all of the next little
simulators um yeah yeah so this is good
okay we have 10 we have 10 more i want
to look at um
i actually want to look at them as many
of them as we can
so um okay
[Music]
so remember we said that everything is
relational everything relates to each
other
nothing is just in a vacuum so this is
showing you the relational dynamics
between everything between
experiences vessels realities
cosmologies at all scales they're always
related with each other i and i have a
question would you say that um
would you say that that
the sole particle of experience does
each sxp
does each one have its own like
signature or like shape
or uh
um vibration or energy yes yes yes yes
that's really cool so when sxp and sxp
can be
both
like coherent or harmonious like peace
love
um or it can be uh dissonant and uh
disharmony um it can be anger and
aggression and um
extraction and manipulation so then that
carries a different signature to it
different exactly exactly
and it happens at all levels atlas
it happens at your physical level
emotional level collective level city
level when you come to a city like you
know when i was traveling
you you come to a new city all of a
sudden you feel the energy is so
different than the than the previous
town
because all the particles of experience
of that city
these these particles of experience
they're unique to this city
um
and they're they're that's cool yeah
it's and once you become sensitive to
all these elements
it's incredible it's incredible you you
just are fully alive and fully
connected to everything that moves and
everything that is still around you
it's it's an exhilarating experience
truly
i love that so you're fully alive and
acted and still
which is really important so then you're
you're both in this stillness
of movement like nirvana and yet at the
same time you're fully alive and awake
in the field of
of play that's happening yes that's
right
i love that oh that's so beautiful okay
beautiful
okay so the vessel qualities and
processes as well
okay
nice
okay beautiful
i love it a stable carrier of
experiences
that's great
cool
okay
um unique stable arrangement experiences
nice
yeah i actually am starting to i think
i'm starting to also understand um this
down here a little bit better so
almost as though um
like
only you know when like sort of in
neuroscience as well we've done those
studies with when um something that is
in in unconscious around whether you're
gonna order
like tea or coffee or press the
the green or the blue button
um
then only the individuation becomes
conscious or aware it only then shows up
in the forefront
and then and then boom it goes does that
that dissolves you the t choice
dissolves
and then there's another moment of that
sort of unconscious of what is the next
arising
without
yeah yeah that's cool yeah interesting
um
cool
yep so much nesting okay so this is the
vessel sensorium
information thoughts and ideas desires
heat pleasure and pain pressure light
feeling sound
taste hearing sight touch smell scent
and movement oh that's great
okay so stimulus
the vessel registers it
processes and forms pathways develops
sensory organs and individually and
collectively and then sensory organ is
optimized and then stimulus
yep
cool
nice this is great i love the vessel
sensorium
humanity and technology
nice
what is the day yeah this is what you
were saying what is the right
relationship
between the alive sentient organism and
the algorithmic machine
yes what is the right relationship
between sentience and ai
yeah
that's great
cool
and uh
and basically if there's enough within
um every single one of these major
organizations needs to have um
the
a person talking to the uh the ai
development team about this exact
question right
it's perfect
okay hilly and technology
i see i see okay
the synergy yep to be a super organism
god this is such a good
where the [ __ ] did you get this [ __ ]
this is what we're doing do you
understand that this is what we're doing
right now
this is what we're doing we're going in
with no secret
it's better this
and
i don't know for me it's it's it's
terrifying i'm sorry
it's terrifying because the people and
the organizations that are building it
they don't have this deep
long-term
and awakening and awakened and awakened
they don't have it so they're just
building something to fix something
let me just fix this
m and r i mean let me just do that i
mean what is the implication
so my concern is that
how can we create these awakened earth
and humanity
that is growing at a faster rate
or at least always ahead of the game
compared to the technological capacities
and i i don't know this is a question
that needs to be
addressed
this has to do with time this is still
in development
these last few slides it's the last part
of the book it's still being developed
but time is a big big mystery as well
i love it yeah i love the illusion
mystery of it i love it
it's like it's such a
it's like one of the cutest ones
is is the illusion mystery
um
uh apparent actuality of time because
you can't you can call it an illusion
and everything's eternal and infinite
but then you can also say that it's
absolutely totally in the relative the
most important thing is impermanence
impermanence is like the most important
thing in creation
so it's the simultaneity of permanence
and impermanence which is so fascinating
and time time is the essence of the
impermanence which is so cool beautiful
so cool
got it it's so cool
so cool
okay
um
my gosh
so so um
okay
let's see if i can say this another way
okay
um
so
um
that which looks
when it's been totally
fully recognized
um is
a permanent
it's permanent it's eternal
um and then
that which is one layer from
that which looks like the like the total
formlessness of the comprehen ability to
comprehend
um one layer
it like you could say is like the first
tastes of your character right
right the atlas and natalie character
the first layer in
um that is absolutely impermanent
right yeah and so that's where the play
the play happens right there
love it
yeah yeah cool god we're we're gonna be
such good friends now
okay let's uh let's keep let's keep
playing here we have we have three more
to look at so all of these are still in
development you were saying in
finalization
yes
cool
time is so tricky it's so tricky time
was very very tricky it's still all
draft like what is time what is time
what is time
it's it's very tricky
and how is it linked to this whole model
oh yes what what is um what is the v um
x sxpt what is this acronym
v it's a vessel experience of time the
vessel experience
oh cool got it got it because
for example your experience of time is
different than
somebody else
okay oh cool cool i see so what is your
experience of time how does a vessel
experience time differently and why is
it going oh that's cool yeah based on
its level of realization we could say
yes
yeah
cool the vessel experiences time
differently based on realization which
which
which in a big extent um the vessel
experiencing time differently based on
realization is also
the
um the vessel the way it experiences
creation is based on its level of
realization
correct
wow
that's great great okay so then there's
that and then
reality components
and then
the vessel particle of experience qualia
gosh this is so cool
oh my gosh
wow
wow what a journey
[Music]
so
i would like to share with everyone that
the links in the bio to um both
natalie's website
um so you can find natalie
saytouni.com also the link to
installment it's in soulmate.info
go and check those links out go and
support her there you can
also
find the first volume as well of
installment and then this second version
of insolent get excited will be coming
out by the end of the year and so
support her and support um her the
continuation of her like independence
and artistic expression with being able
to do this
and
um
also if the video brought you value give
it a like help the algorithm out
subscribe to the channel if you haven't
yet also
share the video with other people that
you feel like would find this synthesis
and distillation very interesting
and also comment below with your
thoughts on installment and we would
love to hear your your thoughts on this
um your your resonances with it um as
well the patterns that were discussed
that were synthesized and distilled um
we would love love love to hear from you
and
that is that is all um yeah natalie
thank you for joining us on the show
thank you for having me here
thank you for the beautiful curiosity
and
diligence and uh perfectionism beautiful
thank you
yeah you were such a fun guest and such
a beautiful friendship for us and
yeah i'm so it's the beginning it's the
beginning of the new friendship
okay cool let's um let's uh so i'm gonna
i'm gonna uh end the stream and we'll
just stay in the studio for a quick
minute okay okay all right thank you
everyone thank you thank you
bye bye